horrible horrifying example of political
violence a 41 year old liberal just
murdered a poor 18 year old Republican
kid
specifically because the kid was a
Republican
that's it
there are no additional factors here
this is in in all of the reporting and
apparently in the guy's own words
this 41 year old liberal killed this
poor 18 year old kid
because he viewed the 18 year old kid as
a quote Republican extremist
they had a debate over politics and then
the 41 year old Dem killed the 18 year
old Republican
ran him over with his car
then
the good news is this 41 year old Dem
was charged with vehicular homicide and
then the bad news is because we have
completely abandoned the justice system
in this country when it is politically
convenient for Democrats the guy got out
on bond fifty thousand dollar Bond the
guy's out the guy murders an 18 year old
kid
simply for the crime of being a
republican runs him over with a car then
gets out on fifty thousand dollar Bond
there there are basically no examples of
political violence from the right in
recent years
but one example do you remember there's
one example from that unite the right
rally where uh a right-wing guy
apparently hit a left-wing gal with his
car
and it was considered the worst
terrorist attack ever the guy is for
sure gonna rot if he doesn't receive the
death penalty he was he was considered
worse than Hitler that I mean and he
committed a terrible crime and he's
paying the punishment for it
this Democrat guy committed
the exact same crime
much more clearly by the way too at
least with the unite the right rally
there was a ton of political violence
going on on both sides it was a melee
there was basically gang violence going
on in the street here it was just two
guys it was an older Democrat guy who
got into an argument about politics with
a young Democrat teenage or a young
Republican teenager and then
he decided to get in his car
premeditated no political violence going
on around him and just mow this guy down
and he gets out fifty thousand dollar
Bond you you won't hear about this from
the liberal Outlets
all of the political violence
statistically all of it is coming from
the left and we are getting speeches
from the president of the United States
calling Republicans extremist fascist
domestic terrorists Biden's doj is
referring to ordinary citizens as
domestic terrorists parents who question
their child's curricula in school and
the fact that the kids are being taught
critical race Theory and radical gender
Theory are being referred to as as
extremists real
potentially violent threats in America
and the doj and the FBI are looking into
them it's just so bogus
okay obviously there are two
two Justice systems in America
and so why do I say it again not just to
point out the hypocrisy and try to
reason with the libs and get them to
change their minds that's not what's
going to happen I'm really trying to
reason with the Republicans here and the
conservatives and say hey guys
especially the squishes in the middle
this is all fake never give in an inch
don't talk about January 6th don't talk
about the violent threats from the
Republicans it's all just made up guys
and where it's not made up there is like
the tiniest little minuscule half kernel
of truth that is then blown into
proportions that take it into the realm
of the Absurd meanwhile actual very
clear
violence and threats and all sorts of
other nefarious things from the left are
completely ignored and in fact even
Justified
okay it's just a liberal narrative that
is totally fake just ignore it okay
ignore it and just keep on keeping on
and laugh at these people when they
accuse you of anything
I'm so glad you like that clip now
you've got to subscribe ring that Bell
get the notifications we'll see you next
time
[Music]
thank you